for supporters of julian assange it's a
worrying moment two judges at the high
court in london have ruled the wikileaks
founder can be extradited to the united
states to face espionage charges
assange's partner with whom he has two
young children was there to hear the
decision it's been almost a year since i
stood
outside court
with our victory of the blocking of the
extradition
for the past year and the past year two
years and a half
julian has remained in belmar's prison
and in fact
he has been detained
since the 7th of december 2010 in one
form or another 11 years for how long
can this go on
the decisions based on assurances
presented by lawyers for the u.s
government at october's appeal hearing
they said assange wouldn't be subject to
solitary confinement or held at a
maximum security prison they also said
they had diplomatic assurances he could
serve any prison sentence in his native
australia judges here effectively
decided there was now no reason to
believe assange would be a clear suicide
risk which the original ruling had found
the u.s wants a sans to face trial over
the release in 2010 of thousands of
classified military documents relating
to the u.s wars in afghanistan and iraq
but amnesty international has denounced
the decision saying the u.s charges
represent a serious threat to press
freedom something echoed by his
supporters
wikileaks
was a organization of whistleblowers it
made it absolutely
safe and secure for whistleblowers
to
to bring the truth to the public
all he has done is tell the truth and
done his journey done his job right
it's upset the elites but he has done
his job to tell us what's going on this
decision is clearly a big setback for
the campaign to free julian assange but
it's already taken years to get to this
point and it could be a long time before
we know definitively whether he'll be
sent to the united states
the case has been sent back to the lower
court so a judge can refer the
extradition to home secretary pretty
patel but julian assange's legal team
say they'll try to lodge an appeal with
the supreme court challenging the
american assurances that he won't be
treated inhumanely nadim jazeera london